a winner is crowned on the masked singer
finale a moment full of cheers and also
emotion crazy so I didn't have a chance
to come into the game with my natural
voice and you know a lot of my peers did
and they can accept it this helped me
get my voice out there anymore
t-pain took the top spot but we also
found out who came in second place
I had the time of my life here man and
third place went to this icon I've never
gone through anything like this - we
didn't even know who was on the shelf we
had separate everything seriously
they went to the it degree mm-hmm but
this information not to get out not even
telling the people that we're doing the
show who was doing the show okay so hey
we want masks out of time et was with
the masked singer judges earlier in the
month where they weighed in on the
surprising finale what was it about this
that made it so shocking to find out
this last celeb the last lab because
none of us at all we all brought so many
names
none of us throughout this name and then
when it was revealed we went oh my gosh
how did we not get this and when you
find out why this person did the show to
overcome something you get it so
literally you can't help but just cry
what was it about that final celeb that
was just so shocking was for me because
the last two you would expect after nine
or ten episodes that I would get closer
to the truth but I was even more off in
the well I'm always off and so I'm kind
of like a broken clock I'm correct twice
a day this show in a mad bizarre way it
can be such a transformational journey
for these contestants and it's family
fun it's a good time but the beauty of
it is it's quite emotional as well for
them to be so vulnerable to just share
their struggles their insecurities
there's such strength in that that
beauty of vulnerability so I really
honor the contestants
[Music]